gang that middle-class famous tour is
coming your way and it's coming fast
we just added a bunch of new cities it's
a fantastic time stand-up comedy show
plus we play a little ayg with the crowd
it's a fantastic way to introduce the
new bozos and the new homies to the show
so get the squad and come out and see us
yeah guys in august we're going to be in
red bank new jersey that show is about
to sell out then we're going to seattle
portland september we're going to be in
kansas city springfield and st louis
then in october or in nashville indy
we're in philadelphia yikes coming home
then december we're in providence rhode
island and boston get those tickets
those shows will sell out see you there
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast this is are you garbage oh yeah
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find out the
girl to be classy yeah but they're just
a big old piece of trash
i'm your host states foley coming at you
on a beautiful day we're down here in
aunt cody's basement she's upstairs
uh-huh making some potato bread okay
that's what she's doing folks
for the neighbors or for the houses are
we expecting company what's happening i
hope i'm wetting my beak on that what do
you mean it's carb free i think dude
she does it with meth gluten free
why is it blue
blue magic my co-host is coming at you
from across the table it's a family
episode just for homies just the bozos
just the gang hanging out together give
it up for my best pal in the whole wide
world some would say the solar system
kj kevin james ryan hey gang thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure you
rate view subscribe on itunes full video
valve on youtube as you know those
numbers are true
[__] babies
and obviously the greatest goddamn
website of all time www.patreon.com
are you garbage you sign up you get
bonus content episodes of ayg you don't
episodes are hard fail
a couple of live streams on there too
the whole thing's a [__] party get
involved ooh the bald guy ain't lying
i'll tell you that right now and how
about a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good he crosses the tees and
dots the eyes he works the ones that
do's god damn it gonna be an ibiza this
weekend give it up for t-bone mcmuffin
toby mcmullen everybody what's up dudes
yeah i'm working the valet it's the only
country that would let me park cars
she's gonna be in there dancing like
[__] tara reed getting white
he took a pill and ibiza
show foley he was cool hanging out with
diplo shout out to diplo ooh that dude's
cool man he's got purple hair yeah he
does all right he's getting a little too
high yeah this is not a show we
typically do what's he doing what's he
pull down on a gig
couple grand what yeah yeah he does all
right hundreds of thousands of dollars i
think depending on the gig what else you
gotta do is show up i don't think he's
splitting it with you either all right
like i have to
all you gotta do is show it with his
laptop right and he's in he's right here
i think it's a little harder than that
these djs get made fun of but you know
oh they're super talented i love when
that wait when that pops in i'm dancing
around popping e-bombs let's go [__]
smoking moon rocks
i wanted to ask you this ask me buddy
that's why i'm here this is our comedy
podcast we're trying to be better people
i don't know but sure
on paper i say i am yeah i'm trying i'm
trying to be a better person to do more
things this that i want to do things
right
okay
i haven't traditionally done things
right uh-huh we don't have a dishwasher
so we wash everything by hand my dish
washing
incredible i like to be poor
my dishwater my dish
washing
uh
practice
has increased
a million fold in the last couple months
i'm washing more dishes
okay i'm not just saying i'll get up
i'll do it just whatever real quick you
know all the guys like it's a project it
takes five minutes ten minutes or we get
in the shower you do it you're done you
don't gotta worry about it uh-huh
i don't know how my assembly line is to
be honest with you i also wouldn't i
don't think you're the most sanitized
guy i would assume there's a couple
pieces of lettuce and spinach stuck on
there i've heard complaints oh yeah
there's a couple yelp reviews out there
i can imagine yeah i don't have a
[__] uh an a rating i can tell you
that but i i really i'm i'm real heavy
with the soap
you know what i mean i really like it i
like a nice scrunchie i like using an
old gym sock the [__] as the sponge
yeah i was gonna ask what your arsenal
was like i could see you kind of what
kind of hardware you were i could see
you rocking with the the sponge attached
to the handle with the soap in the
handle that's pretty good that thing's
trapped dude my stepdad had one when we
were in elementary school hell yeah well
we would go over in the 90s that was
nasa dude we would go over and play with
it like
oh man it'd be me and my brother
posted up at the counter at the sink
[__] hey what uh just get it get a
pot let's see sure we're being attacked
by dawn yeah see how it works on the
kettle
it was like [__] no we were just
doing dishes
fighting over who's palm olive oh man
just doing dishes yeah we're just
[__] my mind dude to see that thing i
was telling my friend i'm like you
should see what my stepdad has i like
good equipment i like [__] getting it
all soaked up in the hot water and
organize it in the sink it's all right
man it's all right that thing we're past
though now we got a we have the [__]
wooden handle like loofah for the for
the cups uh we have a little tiny thing
for like the metal straws we have a nice
like scotch brite but it's not scotch
brite and we got the scrub boy
that's the real scrub daddy the scrub
daddy the thing that's real the shark
tank that thing made like a billion
dollars yeah i take it in the shower
everywhere whoa all right never eaten at
your place
nope that's what
that's your problem
you cross lines yeah that's what you're
not your borders are all wanted i like a
good scrub then buy a [__] remember
my dad used to clean my fingernails with
that scrubbing brush we've mentioned it
and i have one in my shower i took a
picture of it i took a picture of it i
keep forgetting to send it to you yeah i
don't i don't need that i don't need any
i don't need a picture of anything in
your bathroom scrub them elbows my dad
always said you need to scrub them
elbows yes sir
but we have a nice setup okay we have
good equipment she has all kinds of good
stuff but she's out of town i'm doing
all the dishes
you're also making all the dishes very
true you make it sound like you're doing
other people's dishes too like you know
the neighbors do the
like i'm working in a catering home yeah
so i'm doing all the dishes that i make
so okay let's say i got a couple of cups
i got a couple of plates i got a couple
of silverware in there this is what i do
all right you you tell me if i'm if i'm
there if i'm sure so i organized
everything scrape anything off if there
is get it up i take a cup i take the
biggest cup i have i stick it in there i
fill that with hot water and soap i see
where you're going that's where the
silver the silverware sits for a little
bit soak it you gotta do a preset soak
it now my question is
with everything else okay obviously
you're going to do the silverware at the
end do you wash a dish rinse the dish
and put the dish away or do you soap up
the dish sit it back soap up the other
dish set it back some what the cup set
it back do you i do like an assembly
line like that i do phase one first sure
then i rinse
okay
have a smoke
put the under arm put under armor on it
sure and then
and then i put it in the rack uh-huh is
that proper what do you do i don't know
i'm a 1-4 guy boom i like one i clean
the whole thing front to back wow yeah
and then rinse it and put it in rinse it
well i mean we have the dishwasher now
sure so uh but you know a pot every year
i'm doing all that stuff and placing it
pots suck man pots i don't clean the
outside of the pot and my my my theory
is what do you mean if you don't put if
you just right you pull a pot out of
this the sauce is splattering on there
from the other pot you don't clean the
outside of the pot if there's something
on it yeah
huh but my thing is this is very
divisive this is what you tune in for
this is the [__] nitty-gritty um
if you wash the pot or like you pull a
pot out of the bottom right out of the
the cabinet the cabinet right you
[__] boil pasta or whatever you put
your brokens in there you're making
pierogies
oh we are yeah we're making pierogies uh
we gotta get the skillet out too because
i gotta finish one of the brownies yeah
what am i a [__] [__] you know
like a soggy perot oh dude anybody that
gets steamed dumplings or [__]
steamyoza i feel like i'm eating baby's
feet or something i can't do it i can't
they're
too soft and mushy
and warm it's like eating it dude get
that in the cast iron [__] put a
[__] sear it up for a little char on
that for me will ya oh man i can't do it
there was once or twice where patty
[__] tried to hit us with the
pierogies without [__] doing them in
the in the skillet oh no as a little fat
kid like a spoon i would just make them
like that i would boil them that's all i
knew how to desperate time i'm not
[__] yeah i'm not getting the [__]
canola oil out you know i mean that
[__] bobby flay what are you doing i
just learned you're supposed to put them
in the pan i always thought they just
sucked
man
you're eating real the the old world
siberian toby's like an eight-year-old
immigrant it's wild
listen to the far part of queens has bed
bugs
yeah but all right so you're making your
pierogies the outside of that pan unless
you put it in the dirty wet sink
isn't dirty and or wet that's crazy what
do you mean if i just don't you give it
a once-over yeah because the food that's
inside gets around it and on it and the
other stuff like the stuff from the
outside gets all over here be specific
the stuff that's in the pan
in the pot in the pot when you turn it
or whatever it gets on the side a little
bit it's water if you're making
pierogies it's just water but it's
pierogi water yeah i mean like i'm not
like it's not wet it's dry like it's not
dirty i'm a big would you wash your face
with it
with what pierogi water
then it's dirty
what that is that your gauge of things
that's what i want i mean that doesn't
make any i don't even know what that
means
toby you literally said you used the
scrubber from the dishes on your face
hey i'm a dirt ball i'm i'm listen
that's not on the table but what's dirty
about that nothing got on the outside of
it i think if i just boiled peas or
something i'm so sorry my shot my
instinct was to
take a shot of foley i agree with foley
you got to wash the whole pan thank you
pan pot and you agree i am a dirt ball
he doesn't even own a pot and or a pan i
bet he's he's been eating fights
hopefully he's been eating [__] hot
pockets the past [__] three weeks i
got a set of aisha curry jones that are
sick aisha curry the singer what's that
the comedian no steph curry's wife she's
got a whole life
there's that's a tyler
shout out to her
shout out you're buying [__] steph
curry's [__] sister's [__] pots
and pans his wife whatever
it's not even his if it was his maybe
i'll make you pierogies from half court
he's chuckling
he's chucking them in from the family
room
try my new fadeaway line
toby for three
dad you're trash oh yeah where did you
get those they better be giving them out
or something they're really good quality
no they're not that's crazy
that's
his wife come on
what are you doing you get la crew set
what's it called
coconut what's it called we got we got
two crew sets yeah that's nice or a
gordon ram wolfgang puck i'll give you
he put out some decent i mean she's not
known for cooking is she
according to my mom oh god shout out
what are you doing he makes a good set
i can't give me some emmett smith state
knives too
that's [__] nuts dude
aisha tyler cookingwork
some donald glover hand pals
that's it martha stewart that's where
you go you go marth the store you go
[__] man that's enough she knows how
to make a pillowcase i'll tell you that
no name brand pots and pans are better
than the kerry pots and pans you just
bought the branding on that that's it
yeah you're drinking booty sweat dude
ah man this one is a wonky
in the future we should have a line of
something though
sure are you garbage
listen we're gonna take some
solicitations here um a little bit
uh if you have
i want a beer i thought you were getting
a hooker okay
you had to get locked up for some
listening
hit us up if you if you wanna if you
work or own at a beer company not like
you know a guy i want my own kind of
beer i want maybe my own cooking where i
mean if [__] aisha curry is doing it
i can pedal a spatula cooking wear
something kippy's i want to be hey i
want my name all over everything are you
garbage whatevers the chemicals if you
have products or work in that world hit
us up okay we gotta start diversifying
how about action figures
sure yes
that's all i had
okay
um
but yeah oh and whatever i mean
i don't i don't think the outside of the
pot and or pan gets dirty unless you put
put it in the sink then to get it get
that it gets wet and dirty then you have
to do it once over okay that's what i
said but you do each individual piece
each individual piece as it is but now
like i said i have a dishwasher i do i
do a very good rinse and we've talked
about this i'm like
i'm washing it before it goes in my wife
on the other hand throws it in there all
muddy cruddy and it drives me cuckoo you
let a pot sit overnight to soak
when i'm lazy yeah sometimes the dishes
get backed up like depending on schedule
or what you know what i mean like it
falls through the cracks or something it
can get jammed up for sure the kitchen
be can become a mess and counter space
in new york i said when i [__]
when i get a house or i move i want the
i'm like i'm building a [__] counter
that's a mile long i'm out out to the
burbs that's where we're going get out
what are we doing here
wild [__]
it's a knife fight in this goddamn new
york city apartments yes sir
it is oh yeah lost the roaches the bed
bugs the rats ain't got none of them
goldfish
what silverbacks what are they called
silver curls silverfish i had one in my
apartment the other day
man elsa scared the [__] bejesus out
of you he was crawling up my leg
what swear to god he's a little frisky
making a move on a big guy jesus christ
salted in your own home [__] that um but
speaking of this guys uh when you know
when you sign up for the patreon we will
answer your garbage question on air yes
sir um
this one's from matthew is it garbage in
an entire box or bag of something then
bury it slash hide the evidence in the
trash
in order to hide it from a family member
that's not currently in the house or in
the room uh it knows that you ate it so
you're like you've definitely i've done
a lot of that yeah yeah i've done a lot
of that the best move is you get a
couple you wet a couple paper towels
okay don't go through what's in there
because sometimes people can tell the
timeline like oh
i thought the last thing is crazy the
last thing you think people are doing
trashcan timeline math
you're nuts
just in case
you get a couple paper towels you wet
them nobody wants nobody likes that and
do coffee grounds good night that'll
kill the smell too
[__] nobody will know you had pearls
keep the dogs away from you
[Laughter]
and you you cover it with that because
no one's going there and touching that
but i've been busted as a kid for that
i've she's gone through the trash on me
she brought like a whole box of kudos or
something like that came into the house
and we would i would just knock that out
like
an hour or two after she got back from
the grocery store on a sunday just
[__]
what the [__] jesus christ
you know my brother would get to blame
for it i could buy a little tyler i
don't know i didn't do it where you get
the belt
black beauty yeah he used to come out
often um
he's usually just a deterrent but i i
caught the working end of that once or
twice and i deserved it i caught an oven
mitt a couple of times even when i was
like that's she that was the closest
thing she could grab i was like ladies
you might as well be
we having a pillow fight what are you
doing there's the idea ayg oven mitts
there he goes [__] beat your kid for
your feet slap you slap your kid around
no marks
um she would go through what's this and
she would find it so yeah you got to
cover it up there's no shame stop going
through the trash all right this was
years it was the 90s
wild time
one of the big not big things one of the
things that i remember would be uh you
know
you would get jammed up not jammed up
for but i was always worried about uh
you know
my mom finding happy tissues you know
what i mean not sad tissues
or if you know after uh some alone time
you can't just like [__] what are you
a [__] youth pastor you were jerking
off what are we beating around the bush
for fine hey i mean your mom watches so
patty i'm there well she knows what
she's talking about she was there
anything gave me the [__] pornhub
password yeah i mean they wash our
underwear growing up they knew what was
going on
they knew when you were fiddling i know
but that was always i don't think they
did that was always the thing too of
like
of like you just can't open the trash
can and there'd be like a mountain of
[__] you know
allergies yeah exactly like it's [__]
december or whatever i wasn't a tissue
guy so i can't relate
oh you put them in your undies that's
what you mean just let it go
that's crazy do you at least understand
what i'm saying
yeah dawg i know exactly what you're
talking about yeah yeah yeah yeah not
i mean you responded to that with like
the most insane like no i just go i
don't know i go in my underwear i'm like
okay
make me feel like a creep for using
[__] some bounty paper though being a
gentleman i know what the [__] like
bully's like a guy walking around a gun
range is like you [__] keep the
safety on yeah
guy's ready to rock 24 7.
what the [__]
move the firing pin around a little bit
take the governor off this thing
um
this one's pretty good
that we might save for you know
something some might try to make
something special out of it this one's
from uh old dog beauty which is a home
run of a name
uh can we get a garage fridge update
from kippy's castle on henry's home now
that the summer's in full swing
running audit so we can see what denise
and patty are working with also denise
is spelled wrong
i mean i don't want to bring the vibe
down but i can tell you i can tell you
mine right now oh god turned off
out of commission shut down shop club
foley's
vacant for this season really
everybody's away it's my move to come in
and purchase it i'm telling you right
now man i can make a move on it it looks
like the [__] house in legends of the
fall after he had this stroke
welcome back to deep cuts
yikes some people knew what i was
talking about unplugged it's run down
yeah that nobody's playing burned
nobody's partying huh yeah
[__] clothes a little bit damn it's
real sad in there too when that thing's
not on in the summer
just the gas just smells like gas in
there a couple propane things i turned
the grill on for the first time this
summer being bit me
there's this family of squirrels living
in there
yeah it's like it's like a rundown golf
course
okay
she'll take an offer
what would it take for me to come in
there and lease out the backyard
what do you want to do 10 grand for the
month what do you
please come right in five grand for the
month i get to use it you already made
that offer you can't go backwards all
right well i'm i'll write a check for 5
000 bucks
for the month of august if you can pay
cash we'll do five thousand what are you
gonna do what kind of event you're gonna
have there well you guys don't get to
say it doesn't matter and you're not
allowed outside either a bunch of
topless broads running around i got
going on
i'm pressing against the sliding glass
door
[Laughter]
uh
yeah i could use a nice pool to get out
of the city go relax stretch my legs
you're welcome any time come down what
do you mean yeah you have a [__]
fridge cooking up there oh for drinking
warm coca-cola's and stuff [__] that
it's like grey gardens back there kippy
let's talk about helix baby you mean the
best mattress company in the whole wide
world i slept on one last night it's the
one i'm talking about gang you know them
you love them you go to the website you
take the quiz it takes two minutes you
don't got to hang out in some mattress
store with some bozo with coffee breath
that doesn't talk to his kids yeah get
on that helix take the quiz sleep hot
sleep cold big guys small guys whatever
you need they got it yes uh me and my
wife here the good folks at heels were
nice enough to send me and my me and my
bird a mattress twilight the twilight
mattress they answered the questions big
bad moon they taylor just for you it's
fantastic t-bone just got one as well
look at it shout out to the helix um
they're fantastic my favorite part about
it is when it comes it comes in a box
you [__] open it up it's like a
[__] like a bouncy castle a lifeboat
oh baby you better [__] hit the deck
i feel like captain phillips when that
thing opens up it's a good time
uh guys uh if you're looking for a
mattress just take the quiz order the
mattress that's matched to you and the
mattress comes right to your door
shipped for free you don't ever need to
go to the mattress store again helix is
awesome but don't take our word for it
they've been voted the overall best
matchers pick for 2020 by gq and wired
magazines those aren't too slouchy
publications neither so just go to
helixsleep.com garbage take the two
minutes leave quiz they'll match you
with the customized mattress that'll
give you the best sleep of your life
guys if you're in your 20s or 30s or
whatever and you're out there sleeping
on a mattress you got from your dead
nana or somebody you found on the side
of the road get your act together yeah
you want to get laid what's the [__]
deal yeah bring a guy or a gal back and
you got a helix mattress you're going to
have yourself a good old time they're
sticking around for breakfast they have
they have a 10-year warranty uh you get
to try it out for a hundred nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up if you
don't love it but you will they even
have financing options and flexible
payment plans so a great night's lead is
never a great night's sleep is never far
away helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattresses orders and two free pillows
for our listeners at healixsleep.com
garbage one more time get a pen or
pencil pull out your little iphone helix
sleep dot com slash garbage do it kit
bit mobile mint mobile best and the best
tippy mint changing the game talking
about mint mobile here i know what
you're talking about fifteen dollars a
month they cut out the middleman they
pass the savings directly onto you you
don't got to change your number you're
not in some contract get on it now yes
and you might be sitting there like 15
bucks a month sounds too good to be true
i bet they hit you with hidden bj no
nope the secret sauces are the first
company to sell directly to you wireless
service online only they cut out the
cost of retail stores they got a bunch
of stores and a bunch of people working
on
retail out and they pass those sweet
sweet savings directly onto you
um i've said many times my family is a
mint mobile subscriber we've been using
it for years it's easy peasy for anyone
who hates their phone bill mint mobile
offers premium wireless for just 15
bucks a month and give you the best rate
whether you're buying one or four family
and the best thing mobile families their
new age they know what families not 15
people cool families start at just two
lines what are we doing look at that all
plans come with unlimited talk and text
high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network like the big
man said you use your own phone with
mint mobile plane you keep the same
number all your existing contacts
there's no big headache to switch it's
easy peasy uh to get your new wireless
plan for just 15 bucks a month and get
that plan shipped to your door for free
go to mintmobile.com garbage that's mint
mobile.com garbage cut your wireless
build to 15 bucks a month at mint
mobile.com now back to the show all
right this one's from uh chris 10 homie
here we all know where we stand on
kangal hats however what level of trash
are you if you pay for them on a payment
plan and this is that big thing anytime
you check out online now you can get
that clark you can put it on anything
you want you can put it'll be like hey
it'll be 14 a month it'll be 9.99 a
month it'll be 70 bucks that's bad and
you're they're getting a little juice on
that right oh juice i would assume
somebody's getting something on that
yeah that's if it's a 30 hat it's like
i don't know i think it does say
interest-free payments or something like
that that's right that's what we're
doing but i think what it is so like the
website that's selling it probably sells
more if they can use this pay-over-time
thing yeah no [__]
they probably
that
the the company that's charging the
payments like the financing company is
probably getting wetting their beaks on
a percentage of the you know
like hey with us you'll sell an extra
five thousand kangal hats how did the
[__] kangal had i don't know but it's
one of those things if you know if you
don't have the cash on you got a hot
date you need a kangal hat what do you
think
what do you think
is the
lowest amount something can be
for me to put a payment plan on yes i
don't like the payment plans
because i don't like i don't like people
after me no i don't want someone coming
after me in a month i'm bad at that [__]
i'm bad at the [__] paying my bills
my [__] my time owner got shut off
three days ago yeah i just don't pay the
bill
it's bad i'm just a [__] idiot with
it my wife goes the wi-fi is out now i
don't even think about it like i just
got whacked with a 650 [__] con ed
bill hachi but that included a two a 270
dollar deposit that they wanted because
i i was
paying your bill yeah yeah so i just
caught and i was like get rid of that
here's the thing shut up
turn the fridge up a little bit
i'm gonna be cranking some more btus out
here this [__] august it's going to
be hot what do you got me on dial-up uh
this is pretty to bring this up um
what did you say about your fridge
what's your mom's fridge probably not
good they go down the shore i mean she's
got some stuff for probably some capri
suns but i still think those like
eyeballs or those like pickled [__]
peppers or whatever all in there that
[__] stays in there for 10 years 15
chicken feet in the back yeah yeah
they're wonky doesn't i got to do mine
up i plan on i plan on going home
cleaning out the garage getting it nice
for um how's this for ayg product capri
suns with booze in them
they have them i think i think cil ice
does those let's see how spiked iced
teas i think are in a pouch we're
brainstorming
hey we're not committing anything here
we'll circle back on it on monday okay
let's put a pin in that's tablet
um what uh
you're about to do a question i bought
no i bought uh
this is god this is garbage i bought uh
i mean the lady are going to germany
uh for a wedding in a couple of months
there's nice so we're picking out uh
yeah we're getting married so we're
picking out uh
some flights uh-huh
and uh
i
i i bit hook line and sinker on the open
the credit card
i opened a barclays credit card barclays
yeah because she we like flying
lufthansa it's german she has friends
that work there spark places candy what
is it what what's barclays what do they
do barclay center it's like a finance
it's like oh it's like a visa or
whatever i thought it was like cadbury
no i think it's like i think it's like
the british american express type deal
that's my thing that's my understanding
i don't know
it's a bank it's a bank yeah i think
it's a british bank
it's paul [__] where's all the
money mate it's gone so i got approved
uh
but i gotta
what are you getting out of this what's
this guys spend so much money you get
the bajillion miles in the first 90 days
or whatever
so and you get more
they're linked to because we're gonna be
she likes flying left hand i'm a delta
man in the united states international
world of tanza company i haven't done it
much but i'm a big fan of wherever
you're going their airline sure i don't
want to fly delta to [__] spain
i've flown delta to germany and it's
like i want to fly a loco
or whatever there is
[Laughter]
[Music]
um
flying air margarita baby
let's [__] do this spain
mexico um paloma but i i felt i clicked
like the banner ad open the sixth the
open you get the 70 million miles guys
clicking banners he's running out i was
approved
not bragging whoa look at you approved
200 what
not too bad oh man those dumb brits
didn't see that coming also i applied on
the 4th of july suck it
that you [__] red coats
the boys are back baby i just took two
200 and 2 000 what are the 2 200 beans
from you out of the queen's pocket
[__] old broad
let that redheaded guy back in huh
take it away
take a little willy's college money
[__] kippy's sitting on his head
look at you
they know that's one for this they'll
have you in the [__] oh man tower of
london
[Laughter]
diplomatic immunity my goddamn taxes
sometimes
that's a good piece so what did that do
for you immediately getting the flight
nothing nothing i gotta wait to get the
card
[Laughter]
so all you did was buy it i just opened
up a credit card and bought two
expensive plane tickets
uh they don't give you points off the
jump they got to throw some points out
if you spend i think three thousand
dollars in three months i'll get the
[__] whatever the 70 million points
or whatever it is
but you're gonna wait to buy the tickets
before you do that well yeah of course
how much of the tickets over there just
flat retail i walk in the store i think
mine's 7.50 okay i think hers is about
the same why why what she's going for
longer oh okay
yeah yeah gotcha i got a [__] i got
an empire to run here i can't be gone
for [__] four weeks zipping around
the amalfi coast whatever you're doing
where's it at
where's the wedding at germany all right
give me a little frankfurt okay nice
joint
uh they do it weird over there they do
no they do two weddings
okay they do like the civil wedding
which is like at
the
then they go crazy what do you mean what
do you mean
the first one's symbol the second one's
rowdy as civil as in like we're civil
okay
that's pretty good it's rare that i get
lost second when they get buckwild
that's like when you're taking a photo
now a silly one
like a dumb face that's garbage to do
that what
a silly photo yeah kick right a fan uh
no they do like uh
saying cheese they do classy either yeah
one two three [__] copernicus or
whatever i know how to smile we're 30.
all right
um no it's more like uh
smaller it's like a smaller wedding like
close friends and fan maybe like 40 50
people type thing okay and then later
like sometimes like a year later they
blow it the [__] out just like
culturally how they do it okay yeah so
that one's gonna be in spain now are you
going to the little one or are you going
to the big one it's a good friend of
mine
wait so when's the second one when does
the spain blow out i don't know oh it's
down the line a year and a half gotcha
nice or something like that maybe i'll
tag along to that what
just to go over to spain with you
part ways why would what
i might go over to spain while you're
over there i don't like that at all you
can't stop me from getting hungry i
can't i'll make it work
i'll make your work overtime
i need you to uh doing some belly button
whatever you guys doing here
film foley's calling asking me yeah
um
also we probably can't as being two
titans of industry we can't be in that
what if something goes we both can't be
in europe together what if there's an
invasion we gotta have we have to divide
power and split it
but if we both can't be on a plane at
the same time except when we're
traveling if we were there together
except every time we go do a road show
if we were there together we might help
the resistance because we work we work
well together
what right i'll be yelling at you you
fat [__] idiot
our first idea is to do it don't tell
someone you fat [__] idiot
hey listen the truth need to be
entertained right
i was thinking about this is crazy but
this is also like my brain of i can't
not be in work mode um which i don't
want to be that guy
but if i'm going over there
maybe we fly over to our pals podcast
over there i then go to germany you then
come home to try to promote some uh
later uk yeah some later uh european
chat would like to call it
around ideas i wouldn't mind seeing it
sure sure sure ain't it now but if i go
to [__] if i go to london the [__]
barclays are going to be after me it'll
probably get me at the airport
i'm coming out for you hold the wrong
side of the road queen's guard yeah
um
all right this one's a little weird this
is shaw new
10 garbage can here oh that's pretty fun
garbage can here is it trashy for your
uncle who's 45
to brag that he and his son who's 15 got
drunk and laid the night before
oh yeah i assumed different uh you know
he was out with his boys he was out with
his they both went out hey you know not
that bad i don't i think talking to your
dad about getting laid is strange that's
probably the irish catholic repression
in me but that's at a certain age that's
weird i'm not too i'm not too i'm not
against that but it's weird when
if you any if you do anything sexual
with with your with your parents
like
that came out wrong yeah like going to a
strip club with your dad something like
that
well you're both in that situation
of course yeah that's weird but i would
even be like
because what's the point of telling your
dad that you got late it's an instant
turn off for me what
that look over there your dad's [__]
what's your name son get out of here
motorboat
some poor girl um
because like what's the point of telling
the dad like are you gonna then exchange
more stories about i don't understand it
it's weird to me and very off-putting
trying to assert dominance at breakfast
yeah
i sucked
what i'm the one that got my dick sucked
last night you do the dishes yeah that
kind of stuff that's weird
did you get your butt eaten out last
night dad i don't know i don't think so
[__] you're washed and i'm drying uh
yeah i don't know that's all
we have a very uh
uh repressed irish catholic fact that
you wouldn't talk about that stuff you
didn't you didn't your parents didn't
ask you if you had sex for the first
time when you had sex with the first mom
knows i had sex for the first time ever
and i'm married i don't think she knows
she just has a lot of confidence in you
uh no she wouldn't know when like
story if we went to like the strip club
or something like she would know like
birthdays or whatever she's like you
were doubted whatever working there
she was a bottle girl
it's different she was bartended
she was doing neck wrong it was half off
yeah uh that would be uh
you know in passing
my my wife we had like a makeshift
bachelor party
uh
where we ended up at what a gentleman's
establishment yeah we were cousins yeah
but my mom we woke up i get back to my
mom's house because i was in philly i
get back to my mom's house we wake up we
go down
and i get my wife's just like you know
european they you know they've been
talking about bonins since they were
young those nude beaches over here um
she's like
oh yeah they went to the she just
dropped it like we're like [__] i got my
scrambies in front of me and she drops
it in front of my mom like everybody
and i'm like what are you my mom's like
yeah all right we don't you know share
that much here or whatever it was like
well it was just like it got like i was
like whoa hey i was like yeah i don't
need to know everything or whatever she
starts crying calls the priest
throwing holy water at me he's at it
again with those tissues yeah
he tries to hide him but i find them
ah
yeah this one all right this one's from
thomas
thomas burke hey bozos i just became a
ten dollar homie shout out to the ten
dollar house
and i need to know is it garbage to
pre-game before a night out with your
fiance
that might be a little i don't think
it's
one i think it depends on the drink if
she's getting ready and you're having a
[__] in manhattan
i think that's all right
i didn't get that vibe i didn't get that
vibe either that's like [__] shotgun
and celtics or something yeah that
doesn't sound like they're like going
out to dinner it sounds like they're
about to get after it together sure yeah
i don't have that kind of structure we
don't like you know like what are we
going on drinking tonight uh-huh yeah we
don't do that we i used to have that a
little bit
darn get [__] up well when she would
call she start a bar fight look over
she's got a guy in a headlock what the
[__] uh supposed to be shooting darts
here let's go
uh we would go out and get banged up
like together but like also i feel like
my friends would be like
she could hang booze in with they got
like it's not just youtube yeah no i'll
lean up at a bar again yeah no we did
that we've done that a couple times in
germany like if it was just me and her
or whatever we'll go out because like
but if i was visiting or whatever
pre-gaming in general is garbage but i
love it it is [__]
awesome i love the pre-game more than
any when the pre-game ends i get so
upset when people are like getting in
cabs and stuff like no go back to
smoking cigs it makes the night so much
better
alcohol makes things better
wild it really really does
tommy knows what i'm talking about
huh
you guys have been happy i'm talking
about getting hammered and stealing a
city bus or whatever you were doing
you're driving the el train
yeah i'm talking about having a nice
drink like kevin said while she's in the
shower you got out of the shower you're
getting dressed the tv's on
kids are running around yeah i do
it's probably trashier than a night cat
like if you go out i'll go out to dinner
nightcaps and i'll come back to the
house and i got some beers or whatever
then i'll have those that's not a
[__] nightcap you're a dirt ball no a
nightcap you stop at a place and you get
a snifter or something or some kind of
martini i understand you have a leather
jacket on you don't own a leather jacket
yes i do not that fits fair enough
um
i think
uh
no i'd say i was saying in the same
world of i think having a drink after
you go out at when you get home is less
trashy than
the drink before you go out at the house
if it's a seltzer or a [__] ipa or a
bud light because you're you started
your drinking out you're like i had a
couple with dinner i'll go home i'll
have one and [__] watch the end of
the game or whatever for me that's a
little different it's better to be a
little greased up when you when you get
out of the house though it depends where
you're going sure who's sailing uh get
the apps on the table let's go camp
butcherbox season baby best in the biz
love that butcher butcher prime time
grilling out there right now yeah you
don't want that crap from the grocery
store you want wild caught you want
grass-fed you want grass finished you
want
chickens free
stuff again you know who's been sniffing
around the butcher box who's that patty
yep talking about those deals they throw
out every once in a while it's free
hamburger every once in a while it's a
it's a tractor-trailer a bacon she's
sniffing around what i got good deals is
butcher box i'm not even lying this
sounds like it's pretty out when i was
leaving this morning my wife took two
steaks out of the fridge from butcher
box goes we'll have these this week and
i go you bet your bottom dollar we win
yes we will uh every month butcher box
ships a curated selection of high
quality meat right to your door high
quality free shipping from the
continental us no antibiotics no added
hormones packed fresh and shipped frozen
for convenience so you can save time on
your next grocery store trip customize
your own box or go with one of those
because they know what they're doing
they taking all the data they know what
works best they go oh here's our top
salad this is what everybody wants this
is the best stuff either way you get
exactly what you want high quality meat
delicious 100 grass-fed beef free-range
chicken
organic chicken that is pork raised
crate free and wild caught seafood
unbel unbeatable value less than six
dollars per meal on average look at that
six bucks get summer sizzling with this
special butcher box deal for our
listeners free bacon for life
off what are they doing or giving a farm
away it's crazy we're giving the free
range organic farm away crazy called
seafood get in on it now i'm telling you
right now sign up at butcherbox.com ayg
use code ayg get one pack of free bacon
in every box for the life of your
membership what are they doing they're
gonna go out of business
uh throw it in the freezer it's there
plus ten bucks off your first order
that's butcherbox.com ayg use code jyg
to claim this deal now back to that show
back to the show i do like my wife we'll
go like let's go we'll go out somewhere
for dinner then you know she'll be like
let's go let's pop some popping
somewhere
for a dessert
she gets dessert i get two or three
manhattan [__] googly eyed
that's a fun [__] especially in the
village if you're down in the village
you'll have the cheesecake and all the
fish bowl of bourbon please
especially in the village there's a lot
of different plea popping or whatever
popping in there it's nice it's a good
time
all right great question great question
um all right this one
this is from andrew and we've talked
about this a little bit is a garbage or
girl with a pool table in your living
room
i would say so i think the pool table
is trashy and less done right again very
fun good time but it's got to be done
well which is gonna be placed it's
seldom is you're missing a ball the
queues are broken you only have that
little cue with the rake on the end of
it it's not never really a good bridge
yeah whatever the [__] not in the sand
trap
yeah or you have the little the little
guy it's never good the maestro yeah
one's a tennis ball it's [__]
no it's bad done
yeah it's tough man
it's especially when it's like most of
the room and you can never
you have to like if you're in the corner
you gotta [__] go up real high or
whatever it's like that scene from
seinfeld it's a it's a tough look bozo
it's real bad yeah but it's a good time
growing up i never had one i wanted one
oh at some point in all of my iterations
of friends groups someone always had one
sure you know a couple people had it was
fun it was like
when you're [__] 14 or whatever and
like in the summer you got nothing to do
during the day like you got a lot of
time to kill as a 13 year old or 12 year
old you don't [__] work
you're not in camp anymore you're
[__] whatever it's like and going to
somebody's house was a pool table seems
like years yeah dude i remember dude in
eighth grade summer i i still like a
million years oh my gosh they feel like
it's not even all like august it was
eons yeah august felt like [__]
retirement i know you'd gone through
like three different hairstyles already
you know what i mean my heart been
broken 14 times
it was like full of five different
people went on vacation camp was it was
nuts man
coming through that back basement door
somebody sliding glass basement door on
a [__] hot july day [__] ice cold
ac [__] grab the pool cues hit a
couple of [__] brisks like the iced
teas
clean living
right there yeah we had full run of my
boys house
it was i don't know they made a lot of
money i don't know if it was all real or
whatever but it was and it was i mean
his place was [__] it was a 14 year
old's dream like official basketball net
one that you could do this and it would
raise and lower with a glass backboard
like a little duncan oh drop yeah dude
how many times you drop that down to
seven feet and have a [__] day with
the boys [__] doing alley oops
playing knockout the whole nine yards
snuffing each other that's when you were
just like what are we gonna do you just
like let's get let's play basketball
then jump in the pool then that that
only made it till like 11 30. you're
like [__] else are we gonna do for the
rest of the day like being in shawshank
nothing but time yeah time and pressure
ah
those were good old [__] days good
old days uh this one's from bonehead for
life shout out to the [__] bonehead
there he is shout out to him shout out
to boneheads uh is it garbage if all the
cops know your dad and it's not because
he's a pillar of the community ouch
that's smaller town [__] too i would
assume more of a pillar in the community
that's got to be small town stuff
because like if you're known in
philadelphia by all the cops that's a
you're a mass murderer or something yeah
rico charges yeah you're running for
[__] knocking over 15 banks that's
tough for that kid
sure kid's dad was a bozo
yeah
getting busted
there's ever been any real
crime in my world like
lock up crime or anything like that i
told you this but there was two kids
whose mom got caught stealing lunch meat
at the grocery store she's jammed up
though oh yeah
still made fun of the merciless
come on i ever tell you my boy vinnie
with the skinny his mom was in a
shopping bag commercial
and we were all [__] up on the couch
at like three in the morning and it came
on they shot it in our local they shot
it with uh she used to be the rich
borough shopping bag
and she was like i love the deli meat
because they slice it so thin and we're
like what though we're like that's
vinnie's mom
your customer service is always on point
i come here for the deli trees you're
like what the [__]
mrs p what are you doing
[Laughter]
kyle what'd they pay off without i think
she probably got like a [__]
card and they didn't need the money
either they had it
ah man how nuts is that that was like a
[__]
that's one thing that as trashy as we
are
my my my mom would never do something
like that
she would never she would she would
never do something like that also i
don't think anybody in my family would
ever talk to the news
oh did you see what
happened you
no no where keep your head down
off into space [__] see the bugs
flying around here [__] spot i like
turtles
yeah [__] that ah
yeah this one is from tyler just says
catch up with your pizza
i've done it i've done it it's not that
big listen stop man what are we doing
take a step back i'm taking the shittier
version of what's already on there
i have a thing for uh mozzarella cheese
and ketchup because that comes from uh
the pizza place when i was a kid by my
house joe shout out to joe's they would
do much they would do
cheese fries but they would use ours
ours our place was munchies and they
would put it in that [__] to go
with mozzarella yeah they would put it
in the body the tin foil
tin foil to go container
just fries throw them in there then
throw the a hand like food
too much cheese half a italy's worth
dude then slide that into the [__]
into the pizza oven holy hell it was
telling me the ketchup on that wasn't
[__] awesome
yeah i'll give you that i loved it that
was they would also do pizza fries when
i throw a little bit of [__] cz in
there a little bit of [__] tomati
sauce i'm with it oh boy
i love a good pizza fries shout out to
munchies in richmond
how on the nose was it they were open to
like 4 a.m and then they got arrested
for like selling mad weight out of there
the guy got caught with a stick of
dynamite
a couple of duffy's munchies dude that
was like that would that would be like
how are we not all getting arrested
going to this place it'd be like the
only thing open at four in the morning
and you're there eating like no one's
going there four in the morning sit in
the parking lot across the street if i
was a cop yeah that's what i'm saying no
one's going there for the [__] salad
at 4am you know what i mean
getting an early start of the day
yeah that was [__] start checking
receipts who at the mozzarella fries
the calzone fries um that was [__]
man those those cheese fries were all
right they were like 250. there was
another place ig's pizzeria man this is
a blast from the past they used to do
it was in the tiniest shittiest strip
malt ig's pizza but they would do
breakfast sandwiches all day
on a bagel the size of your tits dude
they were [__]
huge
like steering wheels and they were two
bucks
and we would order like there'd be a
group of like 15 of us and we'd order
like everybody we get i want a sausage i
want a bacon
and they would just deliver them to like
whatever parking lot we were skating in
we're like oh we're going to be in like
the what the shires parking lot all
right we'll be by the bank they would
come and like the whole order would be
like you know [__] 30 bucks for like
[__] 60 sandwich it was a [__]
party couple snapples
damn
shout out to the summer
good times
that was like when one kid in the crew
had a cell phone you know what i mean he
had to check his minutes and [__] he's
like minute's left like a radio and um
you're going to use it you got to make
sure you use it right daddy we got two
calls left cat ass get them
talking about dog one is open you know
what i mean
um
all right this one's from snoochie
boochies
poochie
clerk's three yeah never have one red 10
homie if someone forgets to cancel their
card out of a vending machine do you nab
something for yourself and cancel it
afterwards or cancel
for them and then put your own money in
can you do that i thought the
transactions only for a little bit well
what if they do it i mean it could be 10
seconds after 10 seconds is a long time
for someone to leave and someone walk
out because i stand at an atm for about
15 minutes after right i
don't try i gotta see the light flashing
for the card to go in i have to go i
don't trust the transaction
i want to see welcome to wherever the
[__] we are that's what i want to see
welcome to seneca casino or i ain't
walking away uh-uh do you guys check the
thing to see if there's a skimmer on it
do you ever see some of the ones that
they catch they look like it's like
[__] proper
it looks the same
yeah i use the uh the
atm machine that's on mcdougall street
right next to my moons that's outside
yeah and there's a guy in there writing
down your credit card information
it's like the flintstones yeah dude
that's bad
give me a minute
is this a four or an eight
it's an old card there's an iguana in
there with glasses
yeah no that's like you're getting
jacked up yeah
i was i was warned about it by somebody
anything that's not inside i'm a little
weary of
you know what i mean yeah sometimes but
dude if you're if you need cash and it's
late at night in new york
not even late but just at night in new
york and that thing's glowing and
there's like four dudes standing there
and they're like you're like dude i'm
about to get beat up yeah you're [__]
my last 20 bucks i don't like being in
there go i don't like going into the
inside ones you're trapped in the
vestibules like but like they're like
lobbies
and i think they keep them nice and cool
like you mean like a bank yeah oh
they're all right you think so
well i mean there's at least cameras you
gotta have you got to be at least
anything yeah i'm on [__] crime faces
getting the [__] kicked out of me yeah i
don't know there's always homelessness
fodder for social media there's always
homeless people hanging out and you walk
in and you're like oh sorry is this your
bathroom what's the atm machine and it's
some guy cooking dinner
you're coming in come in what is that
saffron
um
all right this is from
damon damon day moon um oh man
kippy is an idiot i think it's i can't
see damon could be from uh fast times
original high demon d-a-m-o-n-e
damon okay
uh is it garbage to only buy your
tobacco where you get your chinese food
that's a big
that was a big philly thing
they always did socks too what
chinese places in philly sold socks as
well they had a couple of different
things yeah they would always have
some other merchandise but that was
always temple star shout out shout out
to t star on temple i think it's on like
broad and
diamond yeah right abroad and diamond
uh
you would call and they would deliver
sigs any place that delivered cigs
delivered yeah you could get you'd be
like hey let me get whatever they would
just deliver you see i think delivery
had to be like
eight bucks or whatever couple egg rolls
yeah you would get chicken fingers and
fries for two bucks 250. they were so
[__] they tasted like the bottom of
china's [__] dude they they went
through [__] grease that hadn't been
changed with in what seems to be 5 000
years
um
but fossil fuel oh man it was so good it
was so good but you get a pack of that
you get a [__] chicken fingers and
fries and a couple of pack of burning
you'll be like i'm doing an order who
wants bernie's who wants six
get them they would [__] deliver them
that's a big thing in philly the
the chinese food stores have
other merchandise yeah where they can
hook you up also the bodegas would have
like socks and t-shirt like sure new
york bodegas are very different from uh
philadelphia while there are some
similarities as a whole it's uh
quite different
chinese place that had socks was usually
a [__] home run yeah a couple of
[__] shrimp rolls so i can do a
little general dowels
anything behind bulletproof glass when
you're drunk is all right delicious yeah
where you got to go in and go like the
making the fried rice fresh
peas are crispy
let's go
not to not too shabby shabba-delic
uh all right this one's from mg kelly
getting a buffalo wild wings gift
voucher as a wedding present it gets
worse it was only for 50 bucks oh that's
bad and he said he's pretty sure it was
a re-gift which of course most gift
cards i feel are some sort of free gift
i wonder who it was it was somebody
close to the i mean that's just hey i'm
a [__] scumbag
that's what that is
[Music]
you came you had a plate probably got
the [__] steak
right
i would i mean probably didn't tip the
bartenders
probably [__] crushed all the pigs in
the blanket mm-hmm you gotta have a
little class when it comes to that stuff
what do you do i remember not tipping
bartenders at cash ba at open bars first
i mean when i was poor like
up until recent i would really ride the
coattails
of the heavy tippers around me and be
like well he i know he gave him 100
early so
10 of that could be mine it's my husband
he's a doctor
i'm a homemaker yeah that's uh that's
tough you gotta
but i understand listen man i've not had
money so i've given what's worse not
giving money like i've there's people i
haven't give given gifts to so what's
worse that or a 50 [__]
true i don't know i've iced people
before i got one or two on me back in
the day i got
yeah
maybe your family
well i'm not gonna give it to my brother
right i mean at the time we were
business partners no i just honestly i
didn't have any [__] money
then
every time i didn't have money i've
never intentionally done it where i
didn't have money and it was always with
the intention of
i'm gonna get i'm gonna mail it next
week when that check comes through or
whatever i've never been like oh i'm for
sure stiff in this person if i got
married
would you would you give me an envelope
of course what would say you're welcome
no get it uh yeah of course what would
that be
in your envelope yeah
i'd be expecting two 200
000 why what that's crazy yeah did you
give me anything yeah i wasn't invited
still a gift card would be nice i know
your mom gave me a gift card did she
your mom gave a yeah that's right she
did i'll stop by buffalo wild west
later today your mom gave my wife some
flowers i think or no that was me i i
did give you stuff i gave you a card
there was no k there was no two thousand
dollars no but there was a gift card
that yeah yeah i think it was for
marshalls
you gave me a marshall's gift card no
[__] i gave her sporting goods what
was it
i gave her a home goods thing that's the
same as marshall i got her flowers i
brought you a whitman sampler
and i got you uh i think
a regular gift card go ahead didn't i a
rate what's a right now like one that's
not to a place
or maybe i got your wawa gift card
and bought sigs on it
hey listen there's only 9 18 13 18 left
on there all right this guy's got me
dead to rights man i want two g's from
me not now not now
no that's after after realizing all that
i would probably do and now i feel bad
for this guy too with the buffalo wild
wings that's tough so yeah to be honest
i've never been there i'd like to try it
out i know there was there was there was
50 stinks a hundo there was a lot of
chatter about them putting one in um
by the gw at the gw bus terminal they
redid that whole [__] thing and there
was a lot of chatter about them putting
one b dubs and g-dubs b-dubs at g-dubs
at g-dub bees it's got a ring to it um
because like all the people i guess for
like are coming from
their i guess their thought is like so
many people commute over the bridge
there that take the buses and [__] of
like they're coming after work hit there
for the game or happy hour we'll meet
there we'll have some drinks well you
know
and man i was like really [__] pumped
to have a [__] b-dubs in the back in
the backyard on a sunday roll down watch
the game with the guys couple of beers
cheer on your favorite teams no
but not anymore chili wings goddamn
coven took that what are you gonna do um
but tobacco
i i can't hate
the 50 gift card unless they knew like i
would assume it's going hey man this is
all i [__] have the only times i've
been to i had to go to a wedding where
it's like i gotta get the [__] suit i
gotta [__] get there you got the
night before you got a hotel room all
that [__] i have a feeling this
gentleman wasn't staying
he drove there and left sure which could
have been but it's also like he gave you
a gift
i've done way i i've stiffed you you
know
true
i've put stuff on enough i've taken
stuff out of the mini bar and skated on
the [__] on the room that's how you
get your blender
so i can't hate it completely okay uh
this is another wedding one and we can
wrap her up have you anyone you know
been cut off at their own wedding have
you ever seen a bride or a groom i would
assume a groom oh yeah way too [__] up
oh yeah a hundred percent
a husband did something stupid it was
awkward the next day for sure yeah all
of a sudden one of them just disappears
she she went up to bed she went up to
bed yeah we put her up the back she was
a long day yeah she's a little too
excited they never just said
dumb bro got [__] blackout it's
always like she was excited she was
probably puking her guts out in the
[__] lobby yeah that's that's a tough
look i you know i definitely uh dabbled
a little too much
during my wedding uh festivities
um
might as you know yeah i think i called
my wife a [__] or something jesus
christ she was trying to take my suit
off me or something to like get me in
bed i was real banged up and brown
liquor runs through me
but anywho that's all water under the
bridge holy [__]
it's all evan williams under the bridge
shout out to jd
brought to you by buffalo wild wings
all right let's wrap her up all right
gang we love you come see us on the road
right we're all over the [__] place
the ticket links in the description guys
we're coming
over to the [__] road baby august
11th red bank news and i've been saying
i said it one time i said a trillion
times those tickets are [__] going so
get them there's only like balcony seats
left and [__]
end up like abraham lincoln you know i
got balconies
i mean
loosely described as balcony seating
yeah nice that's what i'm talking about
gang
we'll see you next week